Okay guys, we're gonna go through 2023.
2023.
, okay. Let's do it.
Okay, let's go. So, we're coming in 2023. Really need to understand where we're
coming from.
Press action wasn't too bad, honestly, in December, January.
Of 2023, which it usually is, like I know it doesn't look the cleanest, but
some not too bad setups in there. But yeah, we're going to be focused on
specifically where we are.
Let's truck this thing then.
I'm actually 2023 price action. Those days 2022, 2023 was the OG price action
days.
Let's see what we've got here then.
Let's just bearish.
Let's show this bullish.
Let's show this back.
Cheers, back bearish, bearish continuation, reversal, reversal,
continuation, reversal, continuation, swing low. So, we're bullish.
M15 intraday.
New swing low down at Asia, probably not going to get used. That's about the
trick news.
We have interest rate decision today. So, that's probably why. That's probably
what will shape price.
That's interest rates. Yeah, interest rates were raised
hence why the data melted. But we're still bullish.
We'll just say bullish run these lows pretty much.
So, looking for longs. A lot of inefficiency.
So, this is technically discretionary considering the way you go into internal
M15,
internal M1. This is M15.
7.5 pip stop on the M15. We're pretty large price range.
1-5. I'm going to go initial balance on everything, of course,
and out.
Everything is set up nicely. Technically part of discussion, also partly London
,
sweet, frank, point of interest. Honestly, I'm going to say empty leg.
Make sure we keep a track on news.
No news right now.
Thank you.
Interest rates increased also for Europe, low prices, deposit facility rates,
and then
press conference in 30 minutes as well. Let's press conference.
Probably not something you want to be longing the back of. Cool.
So, we'll remain bullish, but probably not for long.
That's technically tradable, and that's totally untradable. So, now we're bear
ish pretty much.
New York.
Cool. That looks like it's up, Friday the Fed Affair, benefit. Sure.
I would love to show, but yeah. Let's go to London.
Hmm. Tricky proception.
Depends how you read the handles. It's not easy. Easy proception.
That's a lot easier.
Balance of trade.
All clear today.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Look at this range.
5.7 pips up that entire M15 price tag.
20.25 could never.
So currently in a bit of drawdown.
That's one to five.
Beautiful.
Clean as a whistle.
You will see how clean price action was in 2023.
2023 was really clean price action.
I wasn't trading this specific model, but I would trade in somewhat of a
variation of what we're trading right now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's unfortunate because I'm never going to use M15.
Asia high M15 is my swing high ever, so yeah, I would prefer to sure, but then
if I sure, it becomes discretion.
So it even worth it, although I just leave it, I'll probably trade this short
in the real market, but I'll leave it for now.
Yep, just a problem is it just, it has to be marked as discretion.
I still do want to have a log.
This is also actually, yeah, you know what, this is what this is a good
opportunity to advise you also.
What you want to do is do take discretionary trades, not ridiculous ones, but
ones like this, for example, where I don't see using Asia session high as my
swing high.
Obviously, which we've done the entirety of this session, but instead of just
saying, I would use discretion and I would do this, I would do that, do it.
Because at the end of the day, when I come into the data all at the end, all I
have to do is click one button, I can remove all the discretionary trades and
see the actual data of just the edge.
And then in another click of the button, I can see all the discretionary data.
And it's better to have that data concrete than to just have it theoretically,
because at least if I have it concrete, I can go and look at it and say like,
okay, now it no longer even becomes discretion, because like, when that happens
, I do that.
So it's a good opportunity.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's if we get tagged, I don't know, maybe I don't even get tagged into this.
Depends what my entry would be.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I don't want to use the entire, that doesn't make sense.
One, two.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm going to leave it just purely off the fact that the restaurant board doesn
't even make sense in the live market, I probably wouldn't even take it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, and I'm just being stupid. That was just stupid.
Never in a million years that I've used that, to be honest with you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
One characteristic I do remember of 2020.
It loves origins.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Price-loved origins.
Again, unless you're really not in the price section.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Doesn't surprise me.
I want you to discretion there.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I would have to use discretion for that swing law.
Retail sales.
I don't remember the things like retail sales and stuff back from 2020 through.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Some prices just like that.
We'll be bearish, bearish from here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Bearish.
From 1% exposure to 0.1%.
Okay, that's a reaction.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Break even.
Ouch, thankful.
Yeah.
Ouch.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's just a way price respects the high.
That's the painful part.
I think that would have been such good trade management.
And I could have just been okay with 0.1%.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Um, barely.
Stops are already above this high.
Okay.
What's the risk? One point.
Basically 1.0.13%.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Still technically animated and there's equal highs at the highs now.
Not a huge fan of that but still 0.1%.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Probably moves to break even now at least.
Prices come in, trade it out, tagged out, open, reaction.
If price trades above this, then it's going to trade above these.
Almost guaranteed.
It's equal highs.
It actually wicks through it but it's not traded through it.
Classic London sweep model.
That would be shocking if that's probably not the most profitable model.
In this session.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Held this trade through moderate news, we held it through, held it through a P
PI and built in permits.
But with stops at break even.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Apologies guys, if you can hear any background noise, it should be able to
clean it out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There's actually no news but I don't want to be trading when Asia highs are
still in the open personally.
And for good reason.
That takes us to Monday, 25th, no news.
We are bullish obviously.
That becomes swing low, I'm not interested in trading that.
If we sweep it and reverse, I'll trade it.
What I did forget is like 2023, my trading was so refined.
My wrist rod was higher but the amount of trades I took was lower.
And the areas that I was trying to trade from, also lower.
It's like a 15 minute feather, I got six pips, no news.
This is technically discretionary because we're technically bearish.
With the continuation, now we can consider being bearish.
I want to see pro trade back into this region.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We become bullish, not a technicality.
Then we become bearish really fast.
What is this price action?
What is this?
I don't even know what to trade.
Like, can we get some clean price action?
Here's me preaching 2023, it was clean.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now what was clean is these lead and one shifts.
But too much liquidity.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
M3 inverter, I got, but we need to probably protect.
It's a little bit aggressive to be honest, but it needs to be for the rest of
the reward as well.
I'll take the loss if it needs to be.
But I don't really see another way to try and make this work.
No news, apparently.
Nope.
Yeah, it's unfortunate.
The real M15 waterblock is here.
It's the real move.
But it is what it is.
Now news.
Pretty much, just trading this.
What is true law?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Thank you.
Really?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's just sad.
But the reality is does the life market, you're going to have that as well.
So this is just all part of the game.
And then probably to the target.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Fun fact, I wasn't, was it 2023?
I think 2023 is the year that I created the three kind of pullback.
Fun fact.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Think that's lower.
Whatever that's not, then none of this is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So this is all bullish right now.
Which means if we're going to internal.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No news.
And no trade.
And that takes us to first of March.
So that's FIB.
Up 8%.
I'm going to continue straight through March, but.
I've paid per cent so far, I'll just keep the ball rolling
and we'll have a look at the day after that.